foreign
to a study conducted by the information
system security Association and
Enterprise strategy group cyber attacks
saw an astonishing surge of 63 percent
in 2020 merely a few months after the
outbreak of the covid-19 pandemic and
the situation worsened in 2021 with
breaches already surpassing the total
number recorded in 2020 by 17 as
revealed by the identity theft resources
Center welcome back to our Channel we
will bring you the latest insights into
the captivating realm of cyber security
in today's video we will be delving into
the more sought after careers in cyber
security for 2023 but before we dive
into that let's take a look at some
alarming facts about the current state
of cyber security as if the escalating
number of breaches wasn't distressing
enough the financial repercussions of
the incidents have also been mounting
the average global cost of a single
breed skyrocketed to a stragging 4.35
million dollars in 2022 with the United
States during the brunt at an average
cost of 9.4 million dollars these
alarming Trends have aggravated the
existing skill gap between the cyber
security industry as reported in the 40
and Report 60 percent of organizations
struggle to recruit cyber Security
Professionals while 52 find it
challenging to retain them this scenario
presents a lot of opportunities for
skill experts who can meet the surging
cyber security demands of organizations
if you love to watch these Tech Trends
then like share and subscribe to our
channel so without any further Ado let's
get started before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities for a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to Simply learn's postgraduate program
in cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
link is mentioned in the description box
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
now let's delve into the details of the
top 5 cyber security credits in 2023 but
before that we'll see the agenda that is
we will cover introduction to cyber
security and then we will delve into the
details of top 5 cyber security careers
in 2023 now we'll start with the
introduction to cell security
so the global cyber security Market is
projected to reach 366 billion dollars
by 2028 and more than 1 million cyber
security jobs will be available
however it's estimated that less than 4
lakh cyber Security Professionals will
be trained by them with an expected
industry growth rate of 11 in 2023 and
20 in 2025 cyber Security offers a
fast-paced career with a median salary
of 81 000 in today's interconnected
World cyber attacks occur every 39
seconds with an average of
2244 attacks per day the increasing
frequency of these attacks highlights
the critical needs for cyber security
professionals who can protect networks
and computer systems from unauthorized
access and safeguards valuable data
cyber security is a ground industry that
offers a range of opportunities at
different skill levels and relearn
positions require a high school diploma
or equivalent mid-level positions often
require an associate's degree and
Advance their positions typically
require bachelor's degree let's explore
the top 5 cyber security careers for
2023 and at the top of the list is the
Chief Information Security Officer or
ciso this senior level role is
responsible for ensuring the complete
safety of information within an
organization
cisos develop and maintain Information
Security Programs interact with
stakeholders and address security
concerns a computer science degree and
MBA and relevant certifications such as
certified information security manager
cism and certified information system
security professional cissp are
preferred for this role and the average
annual cyber security salary for a ciso
in the United States is 166 000 and in
India the average salary is 35.7 lakhs
per annum next up we have the security
architect these professionals design
robust security structures to prevent
malware attacks perform vulnerability
tests and provide technical assistance
to security teams a degree in computer
science or information technology along
with skills in Risk Management Network
Hardware configuration and security
Protocols are important for this role
certifications such as CompTIA Security
Plus cissp can boost your career as a
security architect the average annual
security architect salary for this role
in U.S is 125 000 and in India it is 24
lakhs per annum and in the third
position we have the cyber security
engineer these professionals plant
security measures to protect
organizations from cyber attacks design
cyber security platforms and collaborate
with other teams to maintain overall
security
a degree in information technology or
computer science along with networking
skills and knowledge of programming
languages is essential for this role
certifications such as certified ethical
hacker CH and Community Security Plus
can enhance your credentials and the
average annual cyber security salary for
a cyber security engineer in U.S is
ninety seven thousand dollars
and in India it's 6 lakhs per annum and
it increases with experience and it can
go up to 6 lakhs to 8 lakhs per annum
and average annual salary
and let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers hi I'm Philip
I'm 61 years old and last year I
upskilled with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the I.T sector
in various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course of course I must say was
packed with practical examples it was
led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and the
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and now our fourth career choice is the
malware analyst these professionals
specialize in identifying and examining
cyber threats such as viruses bombs
boats and Trojans they develop malware
protection tools analyze attack patterns
and create strategies to mitigate future
risk strong background in computer
science reverse engineering skills and
knowledge of malware analysis tools are
necessary for this road the offensive
security certified professional oscp the
offensive security certified
professional oscp offered by offensive
security of SEC and cissp certified
Information Systems security
professional certification that is
offered by ISC these can be the add-ons
for this malware analyst role and moving
on to salaries the average annual salary
for a malware analyst in US is 86 000
per annum and in India it's 5 lakhs per
annum and with experience it ranges to 8
lakhs per annum that is the average
salary
and moving out last but certainly not
least we encounter the integering role
of a penetration tester or ethical
hacker these Bodacious professionals
specialize in identifying
vulnerabilities with systems networks
and applications they ethically exploit
these weaknesses to provide valuable
insights and recommendations for robust
security fortification this credit path
holds for a strong command of cyber
security principles knowledge of network
protocols hands-on experience with
penetration testing tools and
certifications like offensive security
certified professional that is oscp or
certified ethical hacker CH and
embarking on this thrilling Journey you
can lead to a rewarding and impactful
curtain in cyber security that is you
can have an average annual salary in U.S
around 91 000 and in India you can have
around 5 lakhs per annum as an average
salary and these sellers vary with
experiences so these are entry level
average annual salaries
so these are just a few of the many
exciting cyber security careers
available in 2023 we have discussed the
top five and you can see many owner
article and videos on a website and
YouTube and with the increasing demand
for cyber Security Professionals now is
a great time to consider a career in
this field whether you are just starting
out or looking to advance your career
the cyber security industry offers
diverse opportunities and a chance to
make a real impact in today's digital
landscape thank you for joining us today
and remember to stay safe and secure in
this digital world if you like this
video please like share and subscribe
till then stay safe and keep learning
and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here